the future of space and the secrets of
our planet revealed
welcome back to star talk radio hello I
have some questions now when my co-host
I'm your I'm your host Neil deGrasse
Tyson I'm an astrophysicist and my day
job is as director of the Hayden
Planetarium in New York City you have a
day job you all work at night Wow Thanks
no III don't have a day job I mean I am
right and you you but you work at you're
like okay now but in the show we
interview of Jon Stewart in three
seconds and we have is latest book
sitting right in front of us on this
table earth a visitor's guide to the
human race and when your copy the book
is dog-eared completely appendix I have
this job now that where I have science
stuff and this is funny science that's
my it combines you and me funny in
science is there stuff there you need
some yeah and have a question I want to
know see this is what people people say
to me oh it's great to have an
astrophysicist right by your side I
think what about this what does this
mean um I want to go through my own
private genius I want to go through the
things that John some jokingly some
seriously that he said could be the end
of the world and just quickly I want you
to tell me on this scale of one to ten
what the chances are ecological
catastrophe for rendering us extinct yes
you don't want the likelihood yeah where
one is unlikely ten is likely one to ten
okay I was ecological disaster five of
all the if we do go extinct the chances
of it being ecologic will disaster I'd
say five I didn't know you'd be give me
a test you know that I know I'm just
writing them down or things I want to
know about but I have to focus on robot
rebellion
zero peel the Spock your back right now
in crime okay
black hole black hole that would be if
you had to go that's a fun way to go so
I didn't ask you what you think is a fun
way okay and rapture rapture 9 okay
rapture isn't there a blondie song
called rapture know there's a big
trumpet and a bunch of Christian while
I'm much less convinced of this man
devout Christian so I gotta go get on a
negative one okay even even below this
mutation mutation I know I got people in
the labs mutating gene pools so what
about so instead of an epidemic or
pandemic oh you know pandemics right
before we had airplanes moving people
back and forth transporting the germs
with them you have to go like Conestoga
to take a dot you know someone who is
German tested from one place to another
and even then they didn't get very far
right and so nowadays you've we can any
disease a bug that shows up in one place
it can be all around the world that's
much faster than it otherwise would have
been take them to get there so I put a
pandemic very high I go seven times then
had planes everyone everybody everybody
in the black then the plague and
everything everything okay and then the
last one was alien invasion alien
invasion with aliens coming to suck our
blood they always make him out to be bad
what if aliens just came and wanted
unique places
remember when Hawking gave the warning
that aliens are probably be evil and
enslave us I I think his concept of that
is a feat it's a mirror held up to the
human race because it was how we know we
and it's what we've done it's what we
not only we've been doing it's been
there been doing it that's right any
mismatch the bigger stick wins the
biggest ed wealth or more I'm speaking
in a more modern sense whoever who's got
the best
the more advanced technology wins and so
any alien who's crossing the galaxy to
visit earth so shouldn't Japanese people
so I'm just saying aliens that come to
earth
if they came to earth across the galaxy
they got more technology than us so
there's a fear factor that they'll all
be evil and my my what I think will save
us is that they'll take it they'll study
earth really hard it'll look at the
species that calls itself dominant and
they will conclude based on all the
evidence available them that there is no
sign of intelligent life on earth you
think we're gonna be so stupid they're
gonna leave it there to them if they're
that advanced leave these ants alive
have no left on you you want pasture a
pile of worms it's Jim wonder what
they're thinking
I want to make make peace with them I've
also seen people stop them just because
they were there because they were in the
way yes so this is the this is how I
think about about the the ends of the
world and I think some are more likely
than others I think we're more likely to
kill ourselves that they have something
in the universe that we then blame it on
because I just see our behavior just
look at our past behavior and take
everything there's anything we want now
I saw a science fiction that she was a
science fiction radio play one time
where the aliens came to earth because
they wanted the hydrogen in our work and
they had run out of hydrogen where they
were they were sucking our word supply
and so they were not fighting us they
were taking our natural resources and
that was a science fiction marketing but
it's a thing but they know that science
fiction often never had Astro 101
because they were learning that 92
percent of the entire universe is made
of hydrogen you don't have to come to
earth so everyone take get it somewhere
else pay attention in Astro 101 because
that's what that's what will work for
you there you can get it closer to your
planet you're listening to Startalk
radio I'm your host in the ole deGrasse
Tyson I mean astrophysicist and I'm
accompanied by my intrepid co-host
and you you you you've got a TV show we
open the hour that way but let me hear
again yeah it's gonna be it's with Joan
and Melissa rivers coming up Jonas
fastest on WE tv and it premieres
January 25th and the my website which is
linked up with comedy comm you can see
on my schedule wearing em on the road
I'm in New York yeah yeah so wait you
guys should know I tweaked the universe
daily and my twitter handle is Neil
Tyson and I'd love to have you as a
follower if you're curious about the
universe I don't tweet what I had for
breakfast unless there's something
cosmically significant about that fact
all right sweet you're gonna learn about
my tooth and in fact did I do that
so I'm good I'm gonna end each each star
talk radio with cosmic perspective that
lands it I'm a tweet tweet tell me to
shut up
okay so I gotta like move on to that
it'll be real quick cuz I think of
humans as our greatest enemy we are our
greatest enemy
unlike the dinosaurs where the universe
was their greatest enemy so right now I
send into the Twitterverse my tweet of
the week most extinct life can blame
natural forces beyond its control but
when we go extinct all we get to blame
is our stupidity sign Neil deGrasse
Tyson signing off for dark talk radio a
program airing weekly but partially
funded by the National Science
Foundation we will see you in a week
I